first up today we've got a story all the
way from
krakow poland the cut reports
a woman there called animal control
on a croissant she didn't realize that
it was a pastry and she noticed a lumpy
creature hanging out in the tree outside
of her house for several days and it
freaked her out so
she called the authorities but when they
got there
they realized it was just a very large
croissant stuck in a tree
first start is anybody curious a little
bit how the croissant got into the tree
um i probably some woman in another
apartment like
stopping herself from eating well i
think it's our duty to show everyone at
home that croissants are
totally harmless and the only thing that
they want to attack are your taste buds
because they're so
buttery and delicious no you know what
they're going to attack is my waistline
i am not
i can't i can't do a croissant
oh how could my
this is peer pressure it didn't work in
high school and it's not going to work
now
this is probably one of the best ones
i've ever had in my life
where are these i had a little you
licked it
i'm enjoying it oh my gosh okay glad
that was good
a little just a little more uh that you
know you know some things they're just
not worth the calories that's worth the
calories it's worth it all right well
we've got a very special guest joining
us on
zoom he made us laugh on modern family
and american vandal
and now he stars in the sitcom home
economics this looks so good take a look
please stop laughing
i'm sorry it's it's kind of funny that's
like
100 a real job yes okay i am helping
people get their pets certified as
emotional support animals
so let's just say i want to bring a
raccoon to six flags
you have the power to make that happen
please welcome
jimmy tatro hi jimmy
hi jimmy will you hit some headlines
with us
of course i would love to yay
all right we're celebrating moms all
week long on the show and yahoo news
reports
that a new study of 2 000 adults found
that
68 would consider their mom to be a cool
mom
now what makes a cool mom a majority of
people said it was having lots of
honesty and openness
with their moms and half said it was
because their moms let their dude let
them do things that other moms
wouldn't do i mean it kind of sounds
like amy poehler and mean girls
remember her she's like i'm a cool mom
jimmy do you think that
you have a cool mom i wouldn't say i
have an amy
poehler and mean girls cool mom but she
is definitely cool in in my opinion in a
lot of ways
the best thing ever is when you get
older and
you get to have a relationship an adult
relationship with your mom and you find
out
what kind of person she really is i
remember before my mom passed away i got
to have deep conversations with her
about
what was your first kiss you know who's
your first crush and that kind of stuff
and to me that made her so cool because
i saw her in this 360 sort of way
you know yeah yeah like once i moved out
and i was no longer living
under their roof it was like we became
way more it was like we were friends
after that before that it was like i was
getting in trouble for things
and once i didn't need to get in trouble
for things anymore it was like oh we can
just be friends now
and talk candidly about things i do
agree it's like
when you're older is when friendship
kicks in and until then it needs to be a
parent-child dynamic
this next story is perfect because if
you like me if you've ever dreamed of
looking like
a totally ripped muscle man which is not
going to happen now thanks to barrymore
well now you can get it without lifting
a single muscle
the new york post reports you can buy an
ultra realistic silicone
muscle suit look at this they come in
various skin colors
i'll take one in every color thank you
they cost about a hundred dollars and
they fit so
snug on you you have to pull them over
you need to apply a layer of baby power
just to get them on and off that's how
tight they are
would you ever wear one of these uh
sorry i just i was just fine
like you know i just
i just fired my scanner i wish i had one
on right now i could just unbutton and
just wow you all
but sadly i don't i know by the way that
would have been pretty great
yeah oh well hello oh oh
jimmy okay well i see you
yours are already arrived yeah yeah
i actually pre-ordered the uh muscle
suit in anticipation of this
conversation
i'm wearing it right now you don't even
need one how cool is that
congratulations on your body
um i'm really excited about this next
story because i think i finally get to
eat this damn hot dog well and i'm never
going to look
like that like that too thanks a lot
keep them coming well if you wish
someone would pay you money to eat hot
dogs
we comparing good food news
food and wine reports that the site
bonus finder is looking for someone to
travel the country's baseball stadiums
and
taste test america's most delicious hot
dogs you can apply online
through tomorrow and get 500
plus all travel baseball and hot dog
expenses paid ideal candidates will be
able to expertly review hot dogs based
on
some key criterias ross what would your
criteria be for a hot dog not even
listening to you just think about how i
have to call in sick for the next two
weeks because i got a new career change
thanks so much
jimmy are you a hot dog fan baseball
game fan any fan
i'm a hot dog fan when i'm at baseball
games and that's about
it i can't really think of any other
occasions where i'm like
i need a hot dog jimmy i have to say
your new show home economics it looks so
good ross you had a question about it
well yeah because your show
it's similar to your real life because
you're one of three siblings but and i
know drew just wants me to ask this
because she's eating her hot dog
that's not true no i know it was my
question but i will let you eat
what now you all you have three siblings
uh but it also put you into a new
territory on the show
you're a dad yeah what's that like
it's a little bit eye-opening in some
ways and there's like a few on the show
i like to say when there's one kid
there's one kid
and when there's two there's six and
when there's three
there's nine do you agree
exponentially in terms of like volume
jimmy have you ever had this experience
too um
i had to play a parent only once before
i was an
actual parent and i was so intimidated i
felt like people are gonna know
from my acting that i don't know what
i'm doing
how do you approach it because i was so
scared that people were gonna see right
through me
i 100 have had some of those moments
where i'm like
just overthinking the little things like
i'll like put my hand on her shoulder
and i'm like is this what a dad would do
dad's like to the dad
like am i hugging her the way dads
hug their daughters like i don't and i
would like go up to carla salza who is
uh plays marina in the show and she has
two kids
um and i was like i would ask her these
questions and she would just laugh at me
i'm like
is that dude that like of me
is weird she's like no it's fine you're
fine the show looks
really special it looks really great and
you've had such an interesting career
and this show
just i think is gonna really resonate
with people
um i love the double entendre of the
name home economics
and um i think it just has it looks like
it has all the feels
yeah it's like something i think a lot
of people can relate to i know my family
can definitely relate to it
it's a lot of sibling drama family drama
um
and just kind of how like the home
dynamic breaks down when
all three kids are making completely
different amounts of money and the
complications that that
brings to a family yeah which i think is
relatable for
a lot of families in america it's been a
pleasure to have you
today thank you so much for coming over
here
great to meet you ladies and gentlemen
home economics airs wednesdays at 8 30
p.m
eastern 7 30 central on abc
jimmy tatro